JORDAN TIGANI: Good
afternoon, everyone.
My name is Jordan Tigani.
I'm a software
engineer at BigQuery.
I was one of the original
BigQuery engineers.
I've been working on
it for a long time,
wrote a book about it.
I'm managing part
of the team now,
but it hasn't been
so long that I've
been managing that I have
forgotten how everything works.
A couple of prerequisites.
This is a highly technical talk.
If you're not here to
hear technical talk,
then it might not be for you.
I'm not going to give
any pitches, or sales,
or marketing stuff.
I'm just going to
talk about technology.
The old only pitch
you'll hear will
be I'm going to try to convince
you that we have some pretty
cool technology in BigQuery.
So the problem that I'm trying
to solve with this talk is
really to solve this
anti-pattern that we see a lot,
which is--
we get a customer, they
start using BigQuery,
everything's working great.
Their queries are super
fast, they're happy,
and then they find that
they hit a roadblock.
They hit something
that runs slowly.
It doesn't run at all.
And they don't
know how to fix it.
And because the
BigQuery architecture
is so different than
what they're used to,
they don't have
a lot of options.
So they either post on Stack
Overflow, they email support.
Or now that we're
selling to enterprises,
a lot of enterprise people have
the phone numbers of Google VPs
and so we get nasty
emails that have
to be solved really quickly.
Can anybody guess
which one of these
is most effective in getting
their problem solved?
Yes, Stack Overflow is
usually going to work.
Actually, no, our support
folks are really good, as well.
But it's nice to have a--
Stack Overflow, we
have a community
of people that are quite helpful
and often they work for free
and are very helpful.
So I'm going to walk through
some BigQuery query plans
and show you how those query
plans map to the architecture.
And I'm going to go
into the architecture
and try to give you an
idea of a mental model
so you can develop an intuition
about what's going to work,
what's not going to work.
This talk is called
Advanced BigQuery.
I'm not going to show a whole
lot of advanced BigQuery
features.
I'm just going to try to
show how an advanced BigQuery
user would use BigQuery.
To start out I'm going
to review, a little bit,
the architecture of Dremel,
which is the query engine
that BigQuery uses.
And this picture might
look a little different
if you've read the Dremel paper.
Things have changed in
the last couple of years.
It's no longer a
static tree, but we
have a dynamic tree that
can sort of assemble
different stages as needed.
And I'll show a lot more
of that in a minute.
But as always, we read
from columnar store--
super fast, colossus data store.
Highly distributed.
That's one of the
keys to our success.
So let's go through a
simple query execution.
Do a filter and an
account aggregation.
So how does this work?
Stage one, we can
apply the filter.
We can do partial
counts in parallel.
Stage two, then we
can compute the sum
of those partial counts.
You'll see there's some
slot numbers over here.
I'll describe what
those mean and where
we get them in a second.
So this is what the query plan
looks like for that query.
And you can find this
in the BigQuery UI.
I'll show you in a
couple of minutes.
You can see the query
plan from your queries,
but there's a lot
of information here.
So I'm going to go
over it relatively
slowly so it makes it clear.
So here we have, basically,
which part of the query
is running at each stage.
They may look a little
different than the query texts
that you wrote because
this is what it
looks like to our query engine.
So here we're reading
from the underlying table
and we're applying the filter.
And actually, for
this kind of filter,
we can actually push that
into the storage layer
to get a much, much
faster query performance.
But then we're also
doing the aggregation
of the COUNT_STAR at this
level and writing that
to the next stage.
So the next stage, we read
from the previous stage output.
We compute the sum of
the partial counts,
and we return the total sum.
Then there's these four
timing windows here.
The first one is Wait.
And the wait time in this
one is not particularly large
because we didn't actually
have to wait for anything.
One thing to note is
that this only starts
when that stage starts running.
So you can see in the
second stage, the stage
two started running
at the same time
stage one did because as soon
as it gets partial output,
it can start
aggregating the results.
In general, these have
three different colors
or three different gradations.
There's kind of the
faintest one, which means
it didn't really do anything.
There's the darkest one,
which is the average time.
And then there's a
little less dark one,
which is the max time.
So since we're running
these things in parallel,
we have lots of
parallel workers.
This is sort of how we
represent the parallelism.
In this case, Read
didn't do much.
This is reading from
I/O or this was not
a significant bottleneck.
The Compute stage is a
little more interesting here.
The compute stage--
the average time
is actually where we
spend most of the time.
And the max time
wasn't much higher.
So this is actually a
pretty healthy query
or a pretty healthy pattern
because we didn't have
a lot of long tail effects.
And Writes was fairly minimal.
OK, so the next bit of
information that we have
is the Input and Output sizes.
In this query, we read
over a billion rows.
And we output 220 rows.
Can anybody guess what
this 220 number means?
So this is the
available parallelism.
This is actually how
many parallel machines
we're running because
each one of these things
is doing a parallel count
and each one outputs one row.
So we can kind of see, by
using these query plans,
how many resources BigQuery
is throwing at the problem.
And because the wait time
is low, none of these
had to wait to be scheduled.
We can actually
know that this is
how many resources were actually
used during the inquiry.
The next stage then
reads those 220 rows
and outputs just the single one.
So a lot of data
just on one slide.
Hopefully it will make the
next ones go more smoothly.
If we increase the
size of the tables
that we're querying
over, we can look at what
happened to the query plan.
So this is the query
plan for the same query
but just running over a data
set that's 10 times as large.
So we can see this
is 10 billion rows.
It outputs 2000 rows.
And then one
interesting difference
here is, while the compute
time is still very high,
the wait time has
gone from almost zero
to something much higher.
And what this means is that
the available power parallelism
was higher than the
scheduleable parallelism, which
means that we had to wait
before we could actually
schedule some of these.
So ways you can avoid that
would be buy more slots.
You could run over
smaller data sets.
Or have queries that--
the compute stages that
execute more quickly.
So if we increase by
another order of magnitude
to a 100 billion
row data set, we
can see that actually the
compute time has gone down
to a very small amount.
And almost the whole time
are waiting for slots
because we can see here
that we have 21,000 slots.
Or 21,000 is our
available parallelism.
And these numbers get a little
bit important in a second.
So it's the same
query execution,
it just means that we
have a lot more slots.
And we have the introduction
of this scheduler process.
And this scheduler
is what actually
schedules different
pieces of execution
to run on the different charts.
OK, so some background
on BigQuery slots.
We get a lot of
questions on slots--
what they mean, how to use
them, how many you need.
So the slot is a single
unit of scheduling.
It's hard to say what
it actually means,
in terms of resources.
But it is some sort
of physical resources.
Not all slots have the
same amount of resources.
So some can have more RAM, some
can have more CPU, more I/O.
But you can sort of think of
it as one scheduleable unit
of parallel execution.
These can be restarted
by the scheduler.
They can be canceled.
We'll show some
queries in a little bit
that can be canceled.
The other key thing is that it's
not a measure of performance.
So some people say,
well, I want more slots.
How do you get more
slots because I
want my queries run faster.
Well, your queries
are only going
to run faster if
you're exhausting
the available parallelism.
So you're just getting
more throughput.
Often that translates into
faster queries but not always.
So by default, everybody
gets 2000 slots.
That's the amount of
parallel things you can run.
Our scheduler balances
fairly between queries
within a project and then
between projects, overall,
because this is a shared
multi-tenent system.
Slots can be
scheduled individually
for each stage of a query.
And I'm going to
show a slot demo,
if I can wake my computer up.
All right, so this is
the Wikipedia benchmark.
This is a one
billion row data set.
And running this query should
take about six seconds.
Let's see how long
it takes today.
Six and 1/2 seconds.
And we can see that
it had 220 slots.
This is, essentially, the same
thing that we saw earlier.
Here's the 100
billion row query.
And this takes about
20 seconds to run
when we don't do anything else.
And let's try running
the one billion
row query at the same time
we're running the 100 billion
or query.
So what should happen
is the one billion
row query should still get
220 slots because we have
a fair scheduler that says, if
we have two queries running,
each one gets to
use half the slots.
So this query should have run
about as fast as it did before.
And the other query should run,
OK, maybe a little bit slower
than before.
So this a little bit slower.
It's about 20 seconds.
Now let's try running 200
billion row slot, 100 billion
row queries at the same time.
And then we can throw in our
little, small one billion
row query, as well.
Small, one billion.
So if we think of what should
happen when we do this,
the one billion row query
should still get 220 slots.
And then the two larger ones
should split the difference.
So they should each
get about 900 slots
and they should each take about
50% longer or about 30 seconds.
OK, this one took 25 seconds.
That took 28 seconds.
So we can kind of see
how the slot scheduler
works in these query times.
And it generally
works pretty well.
You can see we spent a
lot of time in wait time.
Can we switch back to
the presentation, please?
Can we switch back?
There we go.
OK, so that was sort of
really simple queries.
What if we want to do some
more interesting things?
And what can we know about
the BigQuery architecture
from other queries?
So one problem that at least
initial versions of Dremel had
were Aggregation with
High Cardinality.
So let's say you wanted to
do an aggregation where--
in this case, if there's lots
of distinct values of foo.
So what would happen is we would
compute these partial counts
in parallel.
And then we would push those
back up to the next stage.
But one problem is that we can't
actually remove any information
until we've seen all of it.
So this master node has
to see, in this case,
that even though they only
get five from Z that they have
to keep that around until
all the remaining nodes
have completed.
And then only finally
after the lower level
nodes have completed can
they apply the limit.
This would often overwhelm
this master node.
So we don't do that anymore.
We use shuffle in the middle.
Or in general, we
don't use that anymore.
So if we have the
same input data,
we're going to apply another
step which does a shuffle.
And so what shuffle
does is it says,
OK, we're going to put
all of the things that
hash into this bucket
over here and put
all the things that hash
into this bucket over here.
And because we have all
of the As on the one
side and all of the
Zs on the other side,
we can sort of make logical
decisions about those.
We can apply the
limit at this node
before we then send it
up to the master node.
So this makes it scale
a lot more nicely.
So how does this look
in the query plan?
So here's an example
using the same data set.
And a couple of
things to call out.
So you can see the shuffle here.
You can see that when
we do this aggregation,
we write to a shuffle by hash.
So that's going to hash
these into a number
of different buckets.
And then we can also see that
this number is now much higher.
It's no longer the source
number of slots that we used.
This is the number
of shuffle sinks.
So this is the number
of how many places
we wrote the shuffle data to.
So just to go back
and reiterate this.
We can apply the partial
group by at the first level.
We do this magic shuffle.
We can do the
remainder of the group
by, sort it, and apply a limit.
And finally, the final
sort and final limit.
Sort of, the merge sort and
end limit at the master node.
And this slide just
shows that we can have
any number of these shuffles.
In the inner query, we're
grouping by language and title.
The outer query we're
just grouping by language.
So we need to do two shuffles.
And that is
generally no problem.
So whenever stage
end doesn't know
how many outputs
it's going to have,
we generally shuffle in between.
This is the one
thing in the talk
that I can't talk
about how it works.
But it is very fast.
It's very magic.
It is an in-memory shuffle.
Which also means that there's
a limited amount of memory.
If you use too much--
just like if you're
using too much on
your local machine--
you start paging
and then performance
starts getting terrible.
So often we get--
every once in a while we
get reports of somebody
who's doing a giant query.
It exhausts their
shuffle limit and, all
of a sudden, their
performance goes
from being very fast
to much, much lower.
And then the shuffle quotas.
We have a default shuffle quota,
I think, of two terabytes.
And that's sort of the actual
in-memory compress data.
But that scales up for the
number of reserve slots
that you have.
OK, so aggregations are simple.
This is all relatively
straightforward.
What if you want to do a join?
So when you're joining
to large data sets,
we applied the same trick.
We use hash and shuffle
to shuffle the left table.
And we shuffle
the right table so
that the matching keys
end up at the same spot
and we can do a local join.
In the query plan, this looks
like this looks like this.
You can see that we're reading
from each side of the join.
We are writing it out
to the stage output
and shuffling by hash.
And then here we can
see the join keywords
are "join each with each."
Now it used to be that if you
wanted to do a large join,
you would have to add the
"each" keyword, which was sort
of nonstandard and not great.
Now we'll figure out if we
need to do an "each" join.
The alternative--
OK and also see
we had to shuffle a
large amount of data.
But in stage three, we didn't
have to read all the rows.
Because we were
doing a limit, we
were able to cancel
the rest of the shards
because we already
had read enough data
and only had to
read a million rows.
So if you're doing
a small join--
if you're joining a large
table with a smaller table,
you don't need to do this
shuffle because that would
be really expensive
to have to move
all of the data in both
tables to each location.
So what you can do is basically
called a broadcast join where
the small table just
gets, essentially,
sent to every single node that's
processing the larger table.
And then we can see
this in the query plan.
So first we shuffled the
right side of the table
but then we coalesced it down.
Because maybe we were
reading 10 different shards.
We wanted to get it
into a single shard.
We shuffled that down
in this pad coalesce
and then we did an
"each with all."
So "all" generally is
a keyword that means
we're doing a broadcast join.
So it gets tricky when
you need to know--
say we're doing a shuffle
or we're doing a filter.
It's hard to know how
many shards you're
going to need in the
subsequent query stages.
So what we do is we guess.
And then if we guess
wrong, we change it.
So here we see in stage two,
we started out with one shard.
That shard-- we needed more
data, and added another shard,
and needed more data, and
we added some more shards.
So this is something that
you'll see very commonly.
We called it Auto Awesome,
but Auto Awesome actually
has several different flavors.
This is just one of them.
And you can see here,
sometimes in the query plans,
you'll see these
shuffle partitions.
These are, essentially,
just us realizing that we
have to add more shards.
So something that people run
into as a problem sometimes
is called a skewed join.
Now, skewed join is when
one of the keys that you're
joining against has a
very large amount of data.
And it generally
only happens when
you have a high cardinality
key that also has--
a single one of those keys
has a large portion of data.
So sometimes we see
this in when somebody
is doing a join on, let's
say it's like, product ID.
But half of their product
IDs are the empty string.
So they might have a million
product IDs and that's
what they really
want to join on,
but when they do this join
the empty string makes
it more difficult to schedule.
I'll show why in a second.
So I'm going to simulate this
by running a query where I just
replaced-- every time
the title has a C in it,
I replace it with just the
string C. So this will be,
essentially, half
of the data set.
And so this is what the query
plan ends up looking like.
So it still runs.
In general, it still runs.
But it takes a lot longer.
I think this might
have taken 20 minutes.
And what you can see
here is this compute time
is all the maximum time.
This is all the long tail.
So we don't even see
the medium shard times.
All we see are the
max shard times.
And that's one key
to know that you're
seeing some sort of long
tail or skew effect.
To just show what this looks
like on the architectural
diagram, we have this one
shard is getting a large amount
of data from one side.
And this shard,
basically, just has
to churn through
all of this data.
It has to do a lot more
work than the other shards.
And we can't just apply the
same sort of re-dispatch trick
that we did for the
aggregations because we'd need
to then reshuffle both sides.
So this is something
that is slow right now.
It's probable that we
will fix it in the future.
But in case you
run into this, it's
a good thing to know about.
Another problem that
people hit a lot is they
do a large "order by" and they
hit a resources exceeded error.
So what actually happens here?
So let's walk
through an example.
As we were doing
an ORDER BY foo,
we have a lot of distinct
values or a lot of values
that are read in parallel.
But in order to sort
those, the master node
has to process-- somebody has
to process all of these things
in order to do the sort.
And you can overload
the master node.
And you can also
run out of memory
if there are too many things.
So here's an example of a query
plan that actually hit this.
Recently we added support for
returning query plans even when
queries fail.
This can help you diagnose
this kind of problem.
But here you see, stage two
failed with resource exceeded.
So you can kind of see.
And it failed on the sort.
So that's a good indicator
that that's what's going on.
So what do you do
when this happens?
Well, you can add a limit.
So in general, if you're
sorting a large amount of data,
you don't really care about what
happens in row one million to--
you end up running
that query because that
was the easy thing.
Which usually
people tend to care
about the things at the top
or the things at the bottom.
So in general, you
can just add a limit.
And this makes
execution much easier
because we can do the partial
sorts at the lower levels.
And we can drop all of the
ones that exceed the limit.
And so here we can see
why this is easier.
And this is what the query
plan for this looks like.
One interesting thing to
see is this output number,
this 220,000.
Does anybody have an idea
what this 220,000 represents?
So we saw that there were 220--
220 was the available
parallelism for this table.
And so the limit is 1,000.
So basically, each one of these
shards is producing 1,000 rows
and sending those
to the next level.
And this query
probably ran very fast.
Just to sort of sum up
some of these resource
exceeded problems
you might run into.
There are cases
where BigQuery fails
and it probably should fail.
So if you're
unintentionally trying
to generate too
much data-- let's
say you're using string
AGG, which basically will
concatenate a giant string
with all of the values
that you're aggregating.
Now, if you're doing that with
a billion different values,
you're trying to create
a single string that's
going to be a terabyte long.
We're going to fail.
Also, if you're doing
analytic functions, which
are window functions, and you
forget to use a "partition by"
or you're trying to do this sort
of a massive amount of data,
that also can cause problems.
Cross join is also a killer.
If you have 200
two-million row tables
and you do a cross
join of those,
you now have a
trillion row table.
But it's easy to
generate massive amounts
of intermediate data
with a cross join
and those often will fail.
So the solution to these,
is to fix your queries
to not do that.
And then there's also cases
where you probably don't really
need the results,
which is the ORDER BY.
And to fix that,
you can add a limit.
And then there's
the cases where you
overload a shard, like the
skewed join that I showed.
And the solution is to
split up your queries.
And this is sort of tricky,
but you can basically partition
your query into two pieces.
One is you run the
high cardinality part
and filter out the one
that is overloaded.
And the second one, you
run just on that one.
And that should be
a much faster query.
And then you have to
combine the results.
It's not pleasant, but it works.
So now a little bit
of a digression on how
to count things in BigQuery.
So there's really
three different ways
to count things in BigQuery.
One is you can use a group
by to come up with the count.
This is kind of a pain
to write in queries.
Also, if you were trying to
count multiple distinct things
at the same time,
it can be really
difficult to write the queries.
But it's an exact and reasonably
scalable way to do it.
The other way is count distinct.
One of the things that people
hated about the BigQuery Legacy
SQL was that count distinct
was approximate, by default.
And we have since fixed that
in BigQuery Standard SQL.
We have quite a nice
implementation of count
distinct.
But it is going to
be reasonably slow
because I'll show in a
second why accounting
distinct values is hard.
And third we have
approximate count distinct,
which is very fast, but
it is an approximation.
This is sort of a new
implementation that we've just
added that uses an algorithm
called HyperLogLog++.
So HyperLogLog++
uses HyperLogLog,
which is an algorithm for
doing cardinality estimation.
And HyperLogLog++ is just
Google's version of that that
applies using a lot of
experience in using this and it
tweaks it a bit.
It has better estimations
at certain cardinality
ranges, better accuracy,
and uses less memory,
and is faster.
In general, you don't have
to know that that's what's
being used under the covers.
You just get accurate
count distinct answers.
So these are some benchmarks
that I ran against our data set
of various sizes.
And we can see that error
is staying under 1%.
But the performance
is much, much faster.
And these are log
lines so it really
is much, much faster
on large data sets.
So we've also added some
HyperLogLog functions
that give you a little
more control over this.
This is kind of geeky, but I
find it pretty interesting.
So one of the things
that you might want to do
is you might want to count
distinct users by language
from the get help data
set, where language
is the programming language.
So this takes, it
looks like, 23 minutes
to run because you're
running count distinct.
But really you probably don't
care about the exact values.
So you can run--
if you use approx
count distinct,
it'll run like 60 times faster.
So that's 22 seconds instead.
But one of the issues when
you're counting distinct
values--
and this holds whether
you're using an approx count
or an exact count.
But if you try to
take some approximate
counts and then sum those up--
so if we wanted to get the sum
of distinct users per language
and then find the total number
of distinct users overall,
those numbers can't be summed.
Because some of those
same users that were using
Perl are also using Ruby.
And it's hard to
know what those are.
So there are some
HyperLogLog functions
that lets you split up the
process of this counting
into different pieces.
And the first one is,
it builds a sketch.
A sketch is a probabilistic
mapping of the values
and the cardinality
of the values.
And so, you can break
it up into two steps.
First you do the in it,
which creates the sketch.
The second, you do the
extract and this actually
will return the same value that
the other approx count distinct
returned.
So why would you
want to do this?
Well, one option is,
sometimes you have PII
and you want to do aggregations.
But sometimes if
you do aggregations,
then you lose the distinctness.
You don't know how many
unique users you have.
So this lets you save a
relatively small sketch.
And then, finally, you
can do the extract, which
computes the distinct values.
But the kind of cool
thing about these sketches
is you can combine the sketches.
So if you do merge,
you can actually
compute the sum of
each distinct sketch.
So you can come up with the
total sum of all distinct users
in get hub.
And so the overall
number you get
is the exact same
number as if you'd
done the number of
approx count distinct.
So to summarize
these, you can use
these to anonymize user IDs.
You can use these--
so there's multiple
HLL functions.
We should be releasing
documentation on those shortly.
OK, so I'm going
to go another demo.
And so now that I've shown
how to do this in general,
let's walk through
a query that is slow
and show how it would actually
optimize it in practice.
If I can type my password in.
OK, so for this one,
I'm going to use
one of my favorite tables here.
And this a petabyte data set
that we built for GCP Next
last year.
So this table is 1.1 petabytes.
It's a trillion rows.
It's part of this
retail data set
that looks like a
retail schema that you
might be used to seeing.
We applied some kind of
advance BigQuery techniques
to this that are best practices.
So here, instead of
having a sales table
and a line-item
table, we basically
denormalized that
into a single row
that has the sale and the
line item as a nested value.
So you can see how
we have this here.
We have the sale
and then we have
each of the line
items within that row.
But there's still a
trillion outer entries.
So actually the inner
entries are probably
something on the order
of 10 to 20 trillion.
OK, so here's the query
that I want to run.
Hopefully that's a
little bit legible.
But I want to show
that, yeah, you
can do complex queries
over data of this size.
So one of the techniques
we're doing here
is we're looking at--
since this table is
partitioned, we're
going to do a partition filter.
So we're going to just
do one month of data.
We're also using
a window function.
So we're doing a
partition in order
by to compute the
running average of sales
for each product.
And we are also doing a join.
So we're joining from this giant
table to our products table.
And I don't want to
make you guys wait
while I ran this query,
but I ran it right before.
And it took two minutes.
Now one distinct thing here
is it only processed 1.8--
or only processed two terabytes.
So there's a couple
of reasons for that,
even though it's
a petabyte table.
One is we only bill you for
the columns that you read.
So we only read a
few of the columns.
And second is we only bill
you for the partitions
that you read.
So we only needed to
read the one month's
worth of partitions.
But there were still
a lot of data here.
And we did run a regular
expression over a lot of data.
So here's what the
query plan looks like.
So what do we see
from this query plan?
So we see that stage
one is actually
where we spent almost
all of our time.
And we notice that the
output rows were larger
than the input rows.
And so that seems
a little bit funny.
But one of the things that we
had to do here in this query
is we ended up flattening
these line items.
So each of the line
items had to be unnested.
And so this is where
we spent a lot of time.
Now these look like
repartitioned stages.
And if you look at that then,
yes, that's what they are.
So it looks like this stage
processed 10 billion rows.
That's an interesting one.
So we look in here.
And we can see that we
didn't "each all" join.
So we did a broadcast join.
So that's positive news.
We know that we didn't
have to shuffle.
We didn't have the
shuffle actually these
10 billion rows because that
would have been expensive.
Or did we?
Actually we did.
So actually, that was expensive.
So this is the stage where
we read the products table.
And so the products table
had two million products
and we filtered it down
to 600 products, which is
why we could do the broadcast.
But actually, it only started
out as two million products.
So one of the things we
could do is, so we're
applying this filter here.
We're filtering on the--
and this is actually one
nice thing in Standard SQL
is we actually
have an optimizer.
We can push this
filter inside the join.
But we're filtering on the
key wallets in products.
If we change this to filter the
key wallets in the sales table,
we'll end up having--
we can push this all the
way into the storage layer.
We can end up having to
read out a lot less data.
And hopefully, this query
should go should go faster.
So let's see how
long this takes.
Come on BigQuery.
So 30 seconds.
So that's a lot
faster, factor of six
to give us the same answer.
Now notice one other option
we could have had was to--
we could have run it on a
smaller set of partitions.
But we want to do the
trailing weekly average
and so if you do it a
lot less than a month,
then that's going to--
you may not get the type
of answers that you want.
So here we see that
the big difference
is in this first
stage where we still
had to read the underlying
seven billion rows,
but we all had to
output 4 billion.
And we can see that this
filter, this regular expression,
was pushed down into
this layer here.
And can we switch
back the presentation?
OK, so that's all I have.
If you like BigQuery, there
are some other presentations
you might be interested in.
There was a data
model-- obviously,
these have already
passed, but they
will be online so that you can
stream them at your leisure.
But thank you.